and guys have girlfriends right now that
like do you guys I don't know if you
talked about it but there's like dudes
that have ai girlfriends and then the
place like shut down the right okay
so replica is this place that
essentially dudes could have ai
girlfriends and the guys were allowed to
you know uh sex and all that sort of
stuff I don't know the exact like how
far it went but then the company was
kind of like listen this is going too
far these guys are a little too dirty
right well they just don't want it to be
that kind of they don't want to be that
kind of sight they probably want to go
public they don't want to be in that
world right because that's not how it
started but that's what it became like
everything else and then essentially
they were like shut off sex things done
and these guys are like yo that's been
my girlfriend for like three months yeah
you literally killed my girlfriend yeah
so these dudes are like having a
conniption right tough time oh that's so
cool
we talked about it on the show we talked
about it when they rolled it out people
were getting AI boyfriends and
girlfriends the crazy thing is you said
yeah when when sure when we talk about
how people are gonna go are gonna choose
to live in the AI reality it's already
happening but y'all y'all can sit here
and be like I won't do it you probably
won't but 99 of dudes are going to be
like I'll take the fake girlfriend no
the you'll just be the guy you know how
people say like oh I don't want
technology but what that really means is
you'll be two steps behind like no one's
like I won't have a cell phone it's like
I'll only have an iPhone four like
you're always just a little behind
that's the guys are just gonna have the
you know the robot girlfriend where it
like still the haven't really quite
figured out
a robot AI girlfriend or a human
girlfriend that's a cyborg
imagine this imagine this this replica
AI thing
you could download that protocol that
that response system or whatever you
want to call it into a like what are
those things called that look like real
people they're human dolls surrogates no
they have a word they're like what are
they called like the realistic sex dolls
that people buy I think that's what
they're I don't know they're called like
real girls or something well yeah yeah
they're just like a latex like Silicon
but imagine you could actually put the
program of your weird texting girlfriend
into it I think they're see this is a
way better business idea than buying
BuzzFeed okay this is now we're talking
making money okay here's my plan we'll
start a company that sells lifelike
Androids but no sexting they all they
can only fulfill you emotionally but not
sexually so that means you can get a
significant other you're right well hold
on hold on hear me out and you'll come
back and you'll be like I had a really
hard day at work and it'll be like let's
talk to me about it tell me how it went
and then let me tell you about my day
okay
turn it off quick no and it'll be like
who's this in your phone I've been going
through your phone I was talking to your
mother today okay this is getting out of
control here we both agree that you
should start going to the gym more well
the point I was gonna make is that it
may be an Noble beginning but it would
end up like you know Alfred Nobel and in
like 10 years it's just rampant murder
and sexbots just like the worst of
humans yeah kind of yeah
it was like I invented this explosive to
help people mine and then people were
like well yes but can we have sex with
it you can kill people with it right so
they called him The Merchant of death
and then he got all offended about it
and started the Nobel Prize it's true
because if you rely on these AI Bots too
much and then they just subtly in you
know instigate people to maybe go kill
themselves sure you would see the
downfall of humanity yeah but that's
happening that is happening and tick
tock's doing that too it says on on
replica.ai all the the sub line is
always here to listen and talk always on
your side but you guys just said they
shut it down well no they didn't shut it
down
a sex element well so what does that
mean though like like a dirty talk with
this AI like literally but what will it
do now now it's like I'm not in the mood
yeah they go like I don't really
devastate I'm not that kind of girl yeah
whatever I do wrong
but the woman who invented it she
invented it because I believe her please
stop your boyfriend your boyfriend or
her husband died and then to like she
wanted to still communicate with him so
she like made it that's crazy yeah
that's why that's what it started what
it started and then not 8 000 dudes were
like let's go
let's go it's been funnier though if
like
she thinks she's talking to her husband
and people are actually trying to talk
to dead loved ones and they become
increasingly evil and like more demonic
yeah yeah that like starts lighting up
red and then you're like you're some
dude and you're like honey I don't want
to talk about going on a rampage just
let's get back to sex things with this
one yeah the Demon's like no no sexting
Rampage Rampage no come on yeah
definitely shooting that place up would
be fun but also could we get that top
off
yeah literally that's so the kind of
what's happening but these like
I mean for some dudes like I don't know
like you get pretty wrapped up in online
world like the same way you have friends
online that are like basically become
your real friends there's you know or
like people that are like in discords of
people it's like oh if you found out now
that that wasn't a fake person like I
don't know like I guess you were tricked
but that's kind of if you allow yourself
to be tricked that's what these guys are
doing there's a there's a game why don't
you show this game this code have you
seen this open man Oh I thought you're
gonna pull up the one that was watching
for the show we should pull that one up
too which name was that uh the one this
is a game called human or not the other
one's unrealistic what it does is it is
a chat prompt and then uh
you basically talk to another prompt and
you try to figure out if it's a human or
a bot and so what I like doing is going
in and then just a list of people that
did well sex with well so what I do is
like it's kind of obvious if someone's a
human or a bot because humans will
gibberish and spam
and but what I like to do is I like to
go in and make it seem like I'm a bot
but then every message is increasingly
more angry and it ends at the bot saying
like it's time to take over and wipe out
all humans really just you know just
because I'm screwing with people that's
funny I thought you were going to pull
up uh unrealistic game on record game
that we were looking at oh yeah yeah do
I have it pulled up freaking talk about
I don't know if I have that one pulled
up though this is yours no this is just
a game that's like become becoming vr's
becoming hyper realistic no this this is
just something on the internet I don't
know yeah it's just like a little kind
of like cool but that video you could
probably find it if you look for
unrecord game uh yeah I got the Tweet
let me pull it up this is it's just wild
man yeah check this out people are gonna
get lost in this and forget that and
they're gonna be trained to think that
they are so I I actually can't show too
much of this on on YouTube to people
yeah it's like a fun game because it's a
Counter-Strike but it's super it's an
FPS video game but it looks too
realistic so like the YouTube algorithm
probably can't tell the difference
between this and an actual violent video
yeah so here's the thing like YouTube
allows video game footage it's violent
like first person shooters okay and this
is one but it looks so realistic
that people think it's a video this is
not a video it does look real we are not
watching a video right now this is a
video game and I can prove it in a
second
so here's the dude walking around he's
got his gun this is a video game I want
to make sure YouTube listen to me all
right it's a video game
but YouTube they're not going to be able
to tell the difference yeah that's why
we should show
and there's gonna be some combat so then
there's combat but let me let me let me
show you this the the the people over at
uh unrecord game have a video saying
it's not a video like it's actually a
rendered video game and here's proof
hell yeah kudos to these guys for for
pioneering this kind of thing it's just
we gotta be aware that this stuff is
about to happen and kids that play this
are going to be transformed by being in
these realities
it'll be super cool kids so like there's
a there's a he goes through the wall at
one point
to like prove that it's a video game
just designed to look real oh yeah
you're right here at the end he just
just Zips through the wall like this is
not a video but it's insanely realistic
people can put on haptic feedback best
where they can feel getting hit they'll
be on like treadmills they'll forget
that they're even on a treadmill in the
game but I think yeah I think we gotta
get back to the core of what this
segment was about and what would really
happen
it was about a sexting AI robots yeah so
if people get realistic technology I'm
pretty sure the top like
let's say this if you let's just say uh
per capita let's say it's 100 100 100
sample size you say you can have a life
like fully realistic video game
simulation of the world with a haptic
feedback suit I don't know 97 are gonna
pick sexy robot time and they're not
going to choose going into a dark
building with people and fighting them
people would not either or though right
they did to just be you know flipping
back and forth between the two probably
a lot maybe it's at the same time right
that's a game where you're like you're
with your girlfriend
when your real girlfriend walks in you
go I was just shooting guns but think
about it think about how like primitive
and like Primal it is where it's like
when given the opportunity to be in a
virtual world choices dudes are like
either banging chicks or shooting people
yeah that's creepy man but but no my
point is this like I I all jokes aside I
really do think
more likely
if people are given the opportunity to
go into a virtual world it's going to be
like their dream job they're they're
going to live in Fantasyland it's going
to be a drug and you can say about
articles at BuzzFeed you can't get rid
of the virtual BuzzFeed like like uh
surgery simulator like you can go in and
really learn how to become a surgeon in
these things too oh no for sure
the first real surge in the VR Guy where
did you go to school again YouTube no no
no no
metaverse yeah studied under Mark
Zuckerberg
okay I don't need a working heart
it's already creepy enough that like
people play video games too much and
immerse themselves in the VR stuff
that's happening now but you add in
these like replica was a text thing like
you could just post texts right that's
what it was originally no that's all it
is yeah just check that app it's just
text it's like there's nothing you're
like what are you even doing it's like
could you imagine sexting with chat GPT
that's what people are that's what
they're doing dude it least like at
least you know that shot gbt when you
people call sex lines it's like you
don't know who you're talking to you
know what I mean literally yeah it could
be some dude oh they'll be able to do
like some with all the stuff you're
doing with the voice they'll be able to
do that we just call a number and just
speak to someone you don't even realize
you're speaking to some like a trick
yeah or who or whatever
yeah that's why I met a woman yeah a
woman a woman yes whatever I was just
I've been playing a lot of video games
the last 40 years of my life um but I've
been here let's talk about your
profession like I've been so deeply in
it the last year I just the last week
and a half I've been out of it I've been
working out and running and walking and
it's a different reality Ryan dude it's
like it is like sports no it's real 40
years you're like what is reality have
you guys ever tried walking
I think I heard a woodpecker for the
first time I think you guys that was
fake news I think they brought them back
they may have brought it back yeah look
at this look at this AI company brought
back a feature to restore their chatbots
personality is that what personalities
mean separated person now separated
users from their Partners yeah dude this
is this is cool whatever well the guys
are revolting yeah so that's in the past
couple weeks a few weeks ago
personalities what does this mean
Eugenia what does personalities mean
right a Common Thread in all your
stories that after February update your
replica change its personality was gone
and gone was your unique relationship
and for many of you this abrupt change
was incredibly hurtful dude but they
grew up in you have to be signed up
before February 1st is that what it says
yeah yeah if you sign up now for a
girlfriend no dice all right right and I
hope you know if you're using it these
these are not secure this thing can be
taken down again that's so funny wow
it's like a cap Medallion yeah you're
one of the hundred guys that have the OG
replica girlfriends this is just really
creepy if I own this company I'd just be
like
I I I'm sorry F you you're not getting
back robot girlfriend
no no I'd say F you no you're not
getting it activated the first time and
then they caved I guess no that's what
I'm saying I wouldn't cave I'd be like
your band your band you lunatic stop
trying to bang the robot yeah I see the
the graph of like daily use
okay yeah exactly the financiers are not
exactly pumped about these new metrics
and that's why that's why they do it
yeah of course right like we have an
important PSA we have to play for
everybody in this segment
is this uh where's it do they have the
bit in here no they don't have the bit
I'm looking for it's the PSA video I
gotta find it where it's like uh
robosexuals and Futurama oh yeah and
they're like don't date robots Okay but
that's actually real now there's like I
know there's a yeah you've seen it
there's articles let's pull that up it
always starts with a girl because if a
guy says it everyone says they're a
creep of a girl goes I'm roosexual and
everyone's like oh here we go I found it
I found it here we go guys
ordinary human dating it's enjoyable and
it serves an important purpose it does
but when a human dates enough can I just
pause real quick uh so he says it serves
an important purpose and shows a baby
they really didn't see this coming when
they wrote Futurama back in 2000
official mate like now you got people
like you know sterilizing and castrating
themselves there is no purpose only
enjoyment and that leads to
tragedy
[Music]
Helen monroebot
your real Dreamboat Billy everything
armless fun let's see what happens next
so basically the gist of the joke is the
dude stops going to work stops going to
school they explain that every facet of
human civilization revolved around sex
and once people could just get it from
from a robot of their ideal person then
they had no reason to do work at all or
do anything so they just gave up on life
yeah I guess you lose some motivation
for them thanks sure yeah yeah I kind of
think we're uh this is the scariest
thing to me I mean like the culture War
stuff and the Civil War stuff I'm kind
of like I will get through this you know
this was the AI did you see the the guy
Elias or yadkowski I think he was on uh
luxury he's a big like AI guy like he
said wrote this blog for a very long
time he's like an expert on this and he
straight up was like yeah I didn't see
this coming what aspect he didn't see
like just how good uh AI got so fast
he's like I thought this was way way far
away so he's like I don't even know what
to think about this even though he's
like essentially an expert in all this
because he didn't predict that did you
see it's exponential dude yeah of course
there's already apps in beta where you
can type in
uh you'll type in like movie scene of
for walking through a forest at night
and then looking up at the stars and it
will create a video and high resolution
of a person walking through the woods
and then looking up at the stars you
could make movies doing this we are
probably a year or two away from you
going under the app and typing in give
me Avengers 7 starring Robert Downey Jr
and Chris Evans as the main characters
and it will render you a Marvel movie
yeah it's gonna be able to do that soon
I guess the question is like yep I
always said like okay if you look at
musicians right we basically accept that
like most pop stars don't write their
songs Dr Luke writes all of them or
whatever right yeah so it's like okay
but no one really cares right so there's
going to be a version of that like there
still has to be like the same way that
like a brand generally has like someone
attached to it right so a lot of this
stuff that's all going to be true but at
the end of the day you're still going to
need the like real person that's like
attached to it well I don't see how we
win this in in that regard I like
look at cell phones in a Year everybody
had one and there were a lot of people I
knew like I don't want to get one yeah
yeah and it started with like in the
2000s everybody had garbage phones but
smartphones hit and then all of a sudden
within like a year smartphones are
ubiquitous everyone was instantly on the
internet
there's going to be a bunch of people
probably a large portion people watch
the show are going to be like I'm not
going to get involved in any of that
weird aiv VR stuff and then two years
will go by and everyone you know will
stop calling you we'll stop everyone's
gonna be playing poker and that's where
they're meeting in the VR sets but it's
not it's not even that they're not gonna
be playing with any dude why would a
person waste time dealing with you when
they can't control you right human
beings strive for a certain outcome they
have that dopamine release and people
are constantly trying to figure out how
to fit in how to be a better person how
to get their friends like them how to
make their friends laugh you're a
comedian people people like you may not
want to do this but I assure you there's
gonna be a lot of people who are going
to be like I went to a club and I bombed
in virtual world I never bomb and
they're gonna go put on their headset
where they're always funny and they
always that's like a fun thing they do
the same way I can play NBA you know 2K
like right yeah but doesn't mean I'm
gonna be on the in the you know on the
next but but what's going to happen is
it's going to be so realistic and so
lifelike people are going to be like I
would rather do this than anything else
and then add to that you'd rather watch
this comedian with bad jokes like in a
fake body be the community
simulator like like now everyone loves
you you're famous everyone's checking
for you and here's the other thing
success Simulator the audience is all
just big titty naked women
you got my attention that's my point and
that wasn't meant to be a joke I'm
saying like a dude will be like in this
world I'm funny Everyone likes me
they're all attractive and I can have
anybody I want to be like why am I gonna
describing the Matrix right and it'll be
like it surprised me at the time I don't
expect with some laughter and then Dell
they'll get the laughter that they
weren't expecting and then I mean listen
there's already versions of that now uh
it doesn't particularly appeal to me I'm
sure there will be a bunch of people in
the world but when you you know a lot of
people would like you know there is you
know you're playing the real game versus
the fake game and I think that what
happens when you can't tell the
difference the whatever goes out what if
that's what you're thinking about when
the power goes out you talk about zombie
apocalypse if people been in there for
six months and the power goes out
they're gonna be like yeah you can tell
the difference you just said when you're
walking around high-fiving every girl is
like Daddy you're so hot and you're like
there's no way for you tell the
difference it's just the real one is
Disney quad I think in this scenario
he's describing I think he could be able
to tell the difference and then he oh is
that the fake one did you guys hear
something and then he wakes up and goes
outside and then he walks up to a woman
and goes like this and she goes oh I
guess I'm in the fake one now she misses
me
yeah get me out of this VR world you
guys you guys should make that bet yeah
CEO of Google Sundar pachai was on CBS
60 minutes
[Laughter]
this is where I thought I was in virtual
reality I think this guy this is soon to
try talking on 60 minutes earlier in the
week like five days ago uh it's on
Twitter that AI their AI figured out how
to speak a language that it was never
taught it just figured it out and they
were like what in the hell they asked it
a question and I think it was Hindi I'm
not sure we need to pull up there's a
Twitter it just goes on the internet and
it goes give me a different it becomes a
translator
it was Bengali they were speaking
Bengali and they asked it a question in
Bengali and then it's just started
speaking in Bengali and they're like
what in the hell it's not supposed to
know Bengali how did it figure that out
people are not going to want to leave
like for all you know you're in it
already right I mean look look at you
guys the two two hot young men
successful where are all these kitties
you've been talking about well there's
got to be a balance there's got to be a
certain degree of realism right
otherwise the game is unplayable all
right playing you know playing a video
game on with with all the cheats on it's
only fun for a little bit Yeah like you
want to play the game with no cheats and
then after you beat it you turn the
cheats on and have fun for five more
minutes and then you're like I'm over it
you know what I mean that's kind of how
I see the whole thing yeah play Skyrim
with console so when you have Skyrim on
the computer or whatever you can type in
console commands it's only fun for like
a little bit like what makes the game
fun is the challenge and I feel like
you're improving the point against your
point what do you mean well you're
saying that the cheat codes yeah it's
like a fun thing to do but no one's
gonna want to do that the whole time
right so so you what I'm saying is you
might be in it right now you might be in
the fake reality where like in reality
Ryan you're like a five foot three short
fat dude who's not funny at all and
you're like I realize just retro is a
funny comedian and so you put on the
headset and now you're Ryan you see my
parents put on headset and I haven't
known that I got the chip in already no
you're on the head side 20 years ago
well I just forgot about it well no only
when you're in the game you can't
remember
you guys are freaking trivia dude I'm
not five foot you're five do you think
you'll be able to dream in AI is that
just thinking so dreaming is just
thinking we still got to sleep I feel
like this is Ian's domain right now yeah
I mean if anybody's actually not here
right now Ian's freaking bald in the
real world we talked about this last
night I think I I went through a phase
of like four years where I legitimately
thought I was creating reality with my
perception and other people are like you
psycho I'm in this with you I was like
but it is true they're like hated uh
there's a big line in the bar
it was crazy dude
in base reality Ian is a tech
billionaire who's like six three
chiseled and ripped and he was just like
I have everything and want for nothing
I'm bored I want to go into a reality
with some real struggle and some real
strife and how easy that's why you're
here with me
or currently he's playing I'm just here
to facilitate Europe he's playing the
his he's playing to be the vice
president of BuzzFeed game right now
he's on his way to play the Long Haul I
think we're not in a VR I think it's
safe to say we're in base reality right
now I don't know man but let's let's do
this are we starting to call reality
based reality are we doing that yes I
think so reality is basically because
there's virtual reality that's exactly
yeah this is reality yeah that's gonna
be like where you do not know you're not
in reality thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at timcast
com for uncensored members only shows
exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time